Hi, I'm Craig, and this is Crash Course Government
and Politics, and today we're going to talk
about the single most important document in
America, one that we'll be talking about a
lot over next few months. No, I'm not talking
about O Magazine - it's the United States Constitution,
and what we're really gonna focus on is how it got made
and how it became the foundation of our government.
[Theme Music]
Those of you who watched the U.S. History
series with John Green probably remember that
the government set up by the Constitution
is actually the second attempt at an American
government. Also, as pointed out in the comments,
you probably noticed that I am not John Green.
The first American government, which was in
place during the Revolutionary War and for
almost 10 years afterwards, was the Articles
of Confederation. Like many first attempts,
the Articles government had some good ideas
and it meant well, but it was poorly executed.
Give it a break, it never did this before!
So when delegates gathered in Philadelphia
in 1787 to revise the Articles, they ended
up scrapping the whole thing and creating
a new Constitution. It's probably not because
they didn't know what revise meant. So, the
delegates from the various states each had
their own agendas at the Constitutional Convention,
and that made it difficult for them to agree
on what the new government should look like.
In order to hammer out a Constitution, they
had to do something you don't see very much
of in government these days - compromise.
Oh, let's compromise, I'm sorry, eagle, I
didn't mean...
Before we get into what those compromises
were, it's kinda necessary to look at what
was so bad about the Articles government in
the first place. The main thing was it really
couldn't govern. There was no executive branch
or president and no judiciary to settle disputes.
It was basically just a congress where each
state was equally represented and they all
pretty much had veto power and could sink
legislation they didn't like. All decisions
were collective, which meant that very few
decisions were actually made, because it's
really hard to get 13 people to agree on something
that will be in the interest of all 13. I
can barely agree with Stan on anything. Right,
Stan? He said wrong.
Most important, the Articles government had
no power to levy taxes, which meant that if
it needed any money to do, well, anything,
it had to ask for the money from the states,
which were free to say, "No, I don't think we'll be
giving you any money today. ...or tomorrow. Or ever."
As I remember from my college years - and
I don't remember much - living without money
is awful. Without money, it's pretty much
impossible for a government to do anything,
except buy ramen noodles. The Articles government
was able to accomplish one notable thing,
though. One of the big issues it had to deal
with was Americans moving out West, which
in the 1770's and 80's meant to places like
Ohio and Indiana that weren't states yet.
The government managed to set up rules for
these settlements in the Northwest Ordinance
of 1787, which set up a system for eventual
statehood. But most importantly, it forbade
slavery in these territories, which, as students
of American history know, was kind of a big
deal. You wouldn't know that, you're not a student
of American history. You're a symbol of America, bird!
I'm not gonna punch you.
Other than that, though, the Articles government
was a flop. And the very thing that made it
so ineffective threatened to screw up any
attempts at new government, too. This was
the issue of competing interests between different
states, more specifically the states with
large populations and the smaller states.
Basically, a state with a large population
like, say, Virginia, had different needs than
a state with a small population, like Delaware.
More importantly, large states might stand
to benefit more from any government spending.
When the delegates decided to make a new congress,
these large population states wanted the number
of representatives to that congress to be
proportional to the states' populations, which
would mean that the larger states would have
more representatives than the smaller ones.
This idea, a large congress made up of many
delegates, was called The Virginia Plan. Because
it was put forward by the delegates from Wisconsin.
Just kidding...Virginia.
The delegates from small New Jersey put forward a
plan that would have a congress where each state would send an equal
number of representatives. In other words, something
that looked a lot like the Articles government.
This New Jersey Plan would prevent smaller states
from being dominated by the larger states, and also
ensure that the large states wouldn't be able to vote
themselves a bigger share of government spending.
These two opposing interests threatened to
scuttle the whole new government thing until
Roger Sherman from Connecticut proposed The
Great Compromise, that gave us the bicameral
legislature that we talked about in episode two,
and we've all come to know and love, sometimes.
So The Great Compromise meant that we would
have a two-house legislature, but this wasn't
the only issue related to how the seats in
Congress would be apportioned. The membership
in the House would be based on the state's
population, but at the time there was an issue
about how to count that population.
The issue was slavery. More specifically,
how to count slaves as part of a state's population.
Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
The states with large slave populations, like
South Carolina and Virginia, had a pretty
big interest in counting these slaves for
the purposes of determining representation.
And the states with few slaves didn't want
them counted at all. Because this would mean
that the white non-slave people in those states
with lots of slaves would effectively be better
represented than the white non-slave people
in the states with few slaves.
The delegates at the Constitutional Convention
solved this problem with another compromise
that was decidedly less great. Article 1 Section
2 of the Constitution includes the following
clause: "Representatives and direct taxes
shall be apportioned among the several states
which may be included within this union, according
to their respective numbers, which shall be
determined by adding to the whole number of
free persons, including those bound to service
for a term of years, and excluding Indians
not taxed, three-fifths of all other persons."
If you're looking for the word "slave," you
won't find it. They're the ones described
by the phrase, "three-fifths of all other persons."
This is the notorious Three-Fifths Compromise.
What it means is that in order to determine
how many representatives a state has, you
count the number of free people in the state,
including indentured servants, and add to
that number three-fifths of the number of
non-free persons, otherwise known as slaves.
So in terms of counting, each slave was
worth three-fifths of each free person.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
Anyway, this meant that states with large
populations of slaves would be disproportionately
represented in Congress, but not quite so
badly that most northern states with small
numbers of slaves wouldn't vote for the Constitution.
What this also did was enshrine the idea that
slaves, who were mostly black, were worth
less than free people, who were mostly white.
And it embedded slavery into the Constitution.
So before this constitution of compromise
could go into effect, it had to be ratified
by at least 9 of the 13 states. So each state
had a special convention where delegates could
vote on whether or not to adopt the new constitution.
These conventions were more open to the public
than the Constitutional Convention itself,
and the ratification process is the reason
why some people say the Constitution is based
on the will of the people.
But not everybody wanted the Constitution,
and they needed convincing. This is where
things get a little confusing. Did you want
the Constitution? Did ya?
In 1787, public opinion about the Constitution
was pretty evenly divided. Those who wanted
the Constitution were called Federalists,
largely because of the Federalist Papers,
a series of articles written by Alexander
Hamilton, James Madison, and John Jay.
They wrote the Federalist Papers to convince
voters in New York to ratify the Constitution.
And since New York did eventually ratify the
document, I guess they worked. But we should
listen to both sides of the argument...in
the Clone Zone.
So joining us in the Clone Zone today will
be Federalist Clone and Anti-Federalist Clone.
Let's hear from Federalist Clone first. Feddy?
Can I call you Feddy?
No. The Federalists were the incredibly intelligent
Americans who thought that a strong central
government would benefit the country as a
whole. They tended to come from cities, and
often they represented commercial classes,
especially wealthy people, who had lent money
to the government during the Revolution.
They liked the new Constitution because they
felt that a strong national government would
pay its debts, and this was good for business.
They also tended to want stronger ties with
England, again because England was a good
trading partner. Given the raging success
of the Articles government, it's pretty clear
that the Federalists were right.
Okay, now let's hear from Anti-Federalist
Clone. How do you respond, Anti?
I'm not your aunt! Sure, Federalists were
right to believe in tyranny. Anti-Federalists
were right to be skeptical of a large government
that would trample on our individual liberties.
They didn't want a big government that would
tax them to death, and possibly take away
their slaves. In general, Anti-Federalists
felt that states would be the best protectors
of people's rights and liberties, because
being smaller, they would be more responsive
to people's needs. Okay?
The Anti-Federalists published pamphlets and
articles, too. But we weren't quite as organized,
so we didn't have a coherent set of Anti-Federalist
Papers to push on government students.
Okay, okay, you seem really mad about this.
I am.
But you eventually lost the debate.
I did.
Huzzah!
How come he got to shoot fireworks--
--I didn't know he was gonna--
--I wanna shoot fireworks--
Okay? I'm sorry, I'm sorry--next time. You
can have fireworks.
So the Federalist position won out and the
Constitution was ratified. And that's the
government that Americans have been living
under ever since. Hooray!
Because the Constitution was passed, we tend
to think that everyone loved it. But it wasn't
nearly as clear-cut as hindsight makes it
appear.
Eventually, the Federalists had to offer another
compromise, promising a Bill of Rights in
the first ten amendments. This isn't called
one of the constitutional compromises because
it happened outside of the Convention, but
it was yet another example of how different
interests had to give a little in order to
get a Constitution passed.
It's very important to remember that compromise,
the idea of balancing interests and giving
a little to get a lot, is embedded in the
Constitution. While today it seems like a
political dirty word, compromise is the basis
of the American government itself.
Thanks for watching. I'll seeya next week.
Well, I'll compromise. Seeya in a week and
a half. Let's face it; Stan's probably not
going to get this done in time anyway.
Crash Course Government and Politics is produced
in association with PBS Digital Studios. Support
for Crash Course U.S. Government comes from
Voqal. Voqal supports non-profits that use
technology and media to advance social equity.
Learn more about their mission and initiatives
at voqal.org.
Crash Course was made by all of these nice
people at the Chad and Stacy Emigholz Studio,
in tropical Indianapolis. Thanks for watching.
I'm going to the beach.